good morning my name is Judd mal I'm a
urologist at Duke University Medical
Center in Durham North Carolina and
really delighted to have people listen
joining us today this is the second of
our series on prostate cancer this
morning and my good friend Larry Karsch
from Denver Colorado is going to be
giving a talk on the oral on Kalitta can
advance prostate cancer we're really
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots we
have a few important announcements I'd
like to bring to you before we begin the
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage questions you can type
in the questions in the Q&A box as dr.
Carson's giving his talk and then we'll
do our best job possible at the end to
get to as many questions as we can you
can engage the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on this click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green Q&A button on the lower left
I'd like now like to introduce today's
speaker for this session dr. Lawrence
Karsch dr. Carr is a co-founder of the
urology center of Colorado where he
serves as an attending neurologist and
director of research he is a principal
investigator with an experience more
than 160 clinical trials certified
principal investigator certified by the
association of clinical research
professionals dr. Carr's has authored a
number of peer-reviewed publications and
serves on the editorial board for
urologist in cancer care and bladder
cancer his active member of aua ASCO
swag as well as society bureau logic
oncology serves on the bladder cancer
subcommittee of the SU of clinical
trials consortium as a member the Denver
Academy
surgeon's I've gotten to know Larry
quite well over the last couple years we
served together on a course at the
American urologic Association meeting on
advanced prostate cancer he's a great
presenter and really knowledgeable and
on this topic so again I'd like to now
turn the turn the podium if you will
over to my good friend dr. Larry Karsch
Thank You Jud and so welcome this
morning to this elaborate cancer
research and oncology virtual conference
what I'd like to focus on are the oral
analytics abiraterone and an salud amide
and maybe answer the question which one
to choose or maybe the more important
question is do i how do i sequence these
or do i even use these in combination so
these are my disclosures you can look at
that for a second there and the topics
that we're going to discuss this morning
are historical review of hormone therapy
we'll look at the mechanism of action of
the oral Anka lytx and we view the data
that led to their approval as well as
the indications and we'll briefly talk
about the resistance mechanisms as well
as some clinical trials in progress and
some new drugs and development and
finally I'd like to close with a
strategy for sequencing these therapies
so this is just a snapshot of our
practice we opened our doors in December
2006 we had the mission of Excellence in
urology and developed the center so that
we can provide all outpatient services
under one roof all gu services under one
roof we have a surgical center we have
radiation oncology imaging pathology as
well as a very robust research
department we have 16 urologists a
radiation oncologist and have
incorporated a medical oncologist and we
have a pathway for metastatic prostate
cancer both hormone sensitive and
castration resistant and we really
believe that it's a multidisciplinary
approach involving urology medical
oncology radiation oncology and we
developed an advanced prostate cancer
tumor board that meets monthly the
doctors in the
practice will send patients into that
board and which time we make decisions
on how to treat these patients and then
we put them into our advanced prostate
cancer clinic which is a weekly clinic
we have two urologists and our medical
oncologists and we rotate those weekly
visits and we also have a bone health
clinic we have been doing this this is
how we actually started a number of
years ago by maintaining good bone
health for men that go on ADT so that it
really involves using our nurses
physical therapists and if these tumor
board meetings we actually have billing
and management involved because in order
to get approval for some of these very
expensive therapies we want to make sure
that we're going to be able to get the
approval when we make these
recommendations to the patients so we're
going to start with some questions now
I'm going to ask you four questions you
don't have to give us answers at this
point but these are the same questions
I'm going to ask you at the end so I'm
doing this in an effort to see whether
or not I can teach you something here
and so just jot down your answer and
then compare it to the one that you have
at the end but the first question is
level one evidence supports sequencing
apparatus beforehand solute amide true
or false the next question is a Beretta
rona and enzalutamide have received
expanded indication for men with
castration sensitive prostate cancer
prior to docetaxel true or false jot
down your answer and the third question
is prednisone is administered with a
burrata room to improve a improved
survival B prevent hypokalemia C
decreased the mineral corticoid
production D prevent drug induced
hypertension and E is a be as BC MD
and the final question is Ludum i should
only be taken on an empty stomach
true or false so modern-day hormone
therapy really began over 70 years ago
with the seminal paper from Charles
Huggins and his team at the University
of Chicago and it was published in the
archives of surgery in 1941 and he was
able to demonstrate that reducing
testosterone levels could lead to
remission in patients with metastatic
prostate cancer and it wasn't until even
though that work was done in the late
1930s he didn't really win the Nobel
Prize until 1966 and a second Nobel
Prize was awarded to Andrew Shelley for
his discovery of loop relay so from the
1940s until the 1980s the mainstay of
treatment for metastatic prostate cancer
was surgical castration and des the
synthetic estrogen was also developed in
that time period but the problem the DES
was that there were a lot of
cardiovascular complications and
surgical castration Lily wasn't that
palatable to patients so there was
really a need to develop something more
palatable and liberal ID was approved in
1985
based on the work by under shaly and so
in the late 1980s inhibiting the
androgen receptor was clinically
evaluated based on research that showed
that androgen receptor inhibition could
suppress downstream signaling and
inhibit tumor cell growth and so class
of medications was developed to the
androgen receptor signaling inhibitors
fluid amide by Kahlil amide and line
dilute amide now these were the first
generation anti androgens and there were
also other hormone therapies that were
used and as you can see the response
rates were not really great they were
blow and they really they're working
real meaningful improvements in survival
or progression and so ongoing research
continues to underscore the androgen
signaling pathway as a key driver of
prostate growth and proliferation and
due to the continuing need for effective
therapies research is really focused on
inhibition of the antigen receptor
signaling pathway so as you can see here
the first step in that pathway is
binding of androgen to the receptor in
the cytoplasm the receptor translocates
into the nucleus and that's where a DNA
transcription takes place so that you
get tumor growth and proliferation and
the disease progression despite medical
or surgical castration signals the
emergence of the prostate cancer
phenotype that can survive and
proliferate in a low energy and
environment and historically that's been
referred to as hormone refractory or
hormone or antigen independent prostate
cancer but among the most significant
advances in the prostate cancer over the
past decade has been the realization
that these tumors are not in fact
hormone refractory but hormone ultra
sensitive and several mechanisms have
been identified that account for the
ability of prostate cancer to progress
despite castration and that is that we
know that the adrenal produces androgen
and even the tumor itself produces
antigen and although we kind of credit
that knowledge to the past decade it was
really jack geller back in the late
1960s who found that prostate cancer
tumor cells have high levels of
testosterone and also these resistance
mechanisms include alterations of the
androgen receptor so that in response to
low and urgent you get over
amplification and older expression of
the antigen receptor
mutations that develop so that these
receptors will respond not only to
androgen ligands but to progesterone
estrogen and even some of the first
generation anti androgens like by
Kalitta mine and then there's the ligand
independent splice variant we'll talk
about that a little later but this
doesn't even need a login to signal the
receptor and so the androgens are
produced the three sites but we're going
to talk about the definition of
castration resistant prostate cancer for
a minute so we have it categorized into
m0 and m1 and what this requires in
castration resistant prostate cancer is
that the testosterone levels are less
than 50
well why 50 well because when they first
started measuring testosterone we
couldn't we didn't have the technology
to measure below but we now know that we
want it less than 50 and probably even
less than 20 to approach castrate levels
and we do have the technology now to
even measure almost down to zero so the
m0 categorization is PSA progression
only and the m1 is radiographic
progression so there's an objective
response that we can see
radiographically so the importance of
distinguishing between these two is
really because these new drugs that
we're talking about these new oncolytic
that have been developed since 2010
really are approved only in the airborne
space there are written no drugs today
approved in the m0 space there have been
a number of trials and therapies that
attempted it but failed there was the
first year there was the end of healing
and antagonists is dial attention and
after Centon they didn't demonstrate
significant clinical endpoints so they
had been withdrawn
there was only one drug that really has
been shown to delay bone Mets and
de NOSSA map 120 milligrams which is
marketed as ex Jeeva so it did
demonstrate a meeting for month delay in
progression of bone nets but it was not
approved for that indication it's been
approved for prevention of skeletal
related events so that's the importance
of knowing the categorization and
clinical drug development for castration
resistant prostate cancer has really
entered a Renaissance era there have
been more new therapies approved since
2010 and in the prior three decades I'm
just going to go through a brief
timeline for you in 2010 the first drug
to be approved on and heesu 5 out of
these six drugs were proved on overall
survival endpoints and the first drug
could be approved was sip sip ulusal tea
which is marketed as Provenge that was
approved in April of 2010 based on a
four month median overall survival
advantage cabeza taxol which was a
second-line chemotherapy and patients
who failed docetaxel
also on overall survival was approved in
June 2010 and then we had the first
in-class human monoclonal antibody
against rank ligand which was Dena some
AB 120 milligrams which is extrema and
that was approved to delay skeletal
related events and that was compared to
the gold standard at the time zoledronic
acid and it was a head-to-head
comparison and it was shown to be
superior and then in December of 2011
the first indication for abiraterone in
the post chemo space was approved and in
August of 2012 the first indication for
enzalutamide and that was approved in
the post chemo space based on overall
survival and progression-free survival
endpoints and then we had the expanded
indication
for abiraterone in December of 2012 in
the Greek a no space and then in May of
2013 we had the first alpha emitting
emitter radium 223 which was approved
also an overall survival and symptomatic
patients with bone metastases and then
the expanded approval for enzalutamide
in the pre chemo space occurred in
September of 2014 and so it continues in
2015 we have in development to androgen
receptor antagonists J&J five six oh two
one nine two seven which was formerly
hair and 509 and odm 201 those are both
drugs that work like enzalutamide and
then we have a novel therapy called
galleta rowan which actually is a
combination of an antigen receptor
antagonist and a bio synthesis inhibitor
and we'll talk about that a little later
in the lecture so these are the two
currently approved androgen signaling
targeted agents have a rat alone and
enzalutamide and I discussed the
timeline on their approvals in the pre
and post chemo space so abiraterone is
an inhibitor of sep 17 or 17 lyase and
what it does this is the mechanism of
action it blocks the production of
androgen in the adrenal gland as well as
in the prostate cancer tumor itself and
it can't block antigen whatever is
produced even in the testicles but it's
really not designed to be a model
therapy so that you really need to
continue in using GnRH analogs or
surgical castration for the testosterone
that's produced in the testes and this
is it's the sip 17 complex is required
for biosynthesis and a Varon blocks the
pathway at 17 lives so that you suppress
downstream signaling of testosterone at
da
that work on the antigen receptor and
the stereo Genesis pathway includes
biosynthesis of
androgens cortisol and mineral
corticoids so we have our sex sugar and
salts and ACTH is the end of pituitary
drives the pathway and it's under
negative feedback control of cortisol so
that when you inhibit 17 lyase with
abiraterone
what happens is the pathway downstream
for cortisol gets suppressed and when
you suppress the cortisol then you
actually increase acth production in the
pituitary and the pathway to the mineral
corticoids is open it hasn't been
blocked by the abiraterone so that you
can get an increased mineral corticoid
effect when you give a rat around and a
reason for having to use prednisone is
to make up for the cortisol which is
lost so they're not really getting a
high bred asone go so it's really a
physiologic dose of about 5 to 10
milligrams a day it's actually 10
milligrams in the for the drug but when
you call administer that you reduce the
ACTH drive and you will suppress that
corticoid the mineral corticoid effect
which can cause some adverse reactions
so abiraterone was first approved in the
Cooper 301 trial this was an
international double-blind
placebo-controlled study involving 1195
patients who were castrate metastatic
castrate-resistant and they had already
received chemotherapy they were
randomized in a two-to-one fashion to
get abiraterone plus prednisone five
milligrams twice daily or placebo and
prednisone and the primary endpoint was
overall survival trial was initiated in
May of 2008 and completed in July of
2009
now the baseline characteristics were
balanced between the both groups the
average
age was about 69 and these patients had
a pretty heavy burden of disease about
90 percent of them had bone metastases
almost half of them had soft tissue or
node metastases and about 20% of them
had liver or lung metastases and the
primary endpoint is shown on this
kaplan-meier curve you can see that it
separates pretty nicely at about three
months and it had a hazard ratio of 0.7
one which was statistically significant
and the overall median overall survival
was four point six months and so that
abiraterone was first approved based on
this trial now we have the Cougar 302
trial this is in the chemo 98 patient
again it was a international multicenter
study double-blind placebo-controlled
and it involved a thousand 88 subjects
who were asymptomatic at least mildly
symptomatic and they were randomized in
a one-to-one fashion again to get
abiraterone and prednisone or placebo
and prednisone and keep in mind when we
talk about the metastatic castration
resistant prostate cancer these patients
all had to remain on their GnRH analog
or have been surgically castrated but
the co primary endpoints were
radiographic progression-free survival
and overall survival and some of the
secondary endpoints were time to opiate
use in time to initiation of
chemotherapy and the baseline
characteristics were balanced in this
group the median PSA was 40 around 40 in
each group and these patients had a
pretty heavy burden of disease you can
see that about half of these patients
had more than 10 bone lesions and about
half had soft tissue or no disease now
the interesting thing about this trial
is that they did not allow visceral Mets
in this trial and these patients have to
have a minimally symptomatic so that
their pain scores you can see that they
were 0 to 3 on a scale of 10 and so this
was one of the culinary endpoints
radiographic
three survival hazard ratio point five
two highly significant and you can see
any separation that occurs even about
two months and so these patients had a
eight point three month advantage in
developing progression if they were on a
veranda room and that's important
because if you can delay progression you
delay all the morbidity and even death
in patients and then the final the
overall survival was also statistically
significant in the first analysis that
was pre specified at the end I was the
first third analysis the overall
survival showed a tendency to
improvement but it wasn't statistically
significant and in a pre-specified final
analysis with a median follow-up of
forty nine point two months it became
statistically significant and there was
a four point four survival advantage and
so these are some of the e's of special
interest in abiraterone
we can we have a higher incidence of
hypertension hypokalemia and fluid
retention and patients on abiraterone
and this really relates to the mineral
corticoid effect and then there are
worth LFT abnormalities which were
higher in the abiraterone group and this
drug is metabolized in the weather like
many many drugs that we take but there
were no patient none of these patients
died of the PATA toxicity and these were
really lab abnormalities and they're
pretty reversible and even in my own
clinical practice i see that when i do
have an issue which is rare
that you respond pretty rapidly after
you stop the drug
so in conclusion abiraterone received
the post and the pre chemo indications
in 2011 and 2012 based on those
endpoints that are described the dosing
is 1000 milligrams a day there are four
250 milligrams tabs that are taken on an
empty stomach with five milligrams
prednisone be ID the prednisone needs to
be taken with food otherwise patients
get some gastric upset but if you have
food in your stomach the absorption and
concentration in plasma is it goes up
dramatically so that they have to be on
an empty stomach and what we do is
monitor if the hypertension hypokalemia
and fluid retention due to the mineral
corticoid excess and lfts are monitored
the label wants you to look at l.f.t.s
every two weeks for the first three
months and then monthly thereafter so
now let's look at as a looter might an
anti-androgen with a high selectivity
for the receptor and in the preclinical
models there was no agonist activities
seen in an Saluda might as it was with
other anti androgens
so this is how enzalutamide works just
like by Kalume i flew to my Lou my and
the other first generation anti
androgens it binds the receptor in the
cytoplasm but unlike those older drugs
it has three mechanisms of action so
that it not only binds the receptor in
the cytoplasm it inhibits the
translocation into the nucleus and once
it's in the nucleus you you don't have
transcription with DNA so this leads to
cell death reduce tumor volume and
decreased proliferation so it was more
potent than the first generation anti
androgens and it was developed in the
laboratory and by kelud amide resistant
cell so as a Ludum I'd work learn by
colluding mine stopped working and this
was the affirmed trial and the post
chemotherapy got the first indication
Forenza luta my 1199 subjects were
randomized in a two-to-one fashion to
get MTB 3100 which was the name of
enzalutamide when it was in development
so they got either the enzalutamide or
placebo primary endpoint was overall sir
secondary endpoints were radiographic
progression-free survival PSA response
time - PSA progression and quality of
life indicators and the treatment arms
were balanced pretty balanced between
both arms you can see that these
patients had a high burden of disease in
bone about 90% and also in this or soft
tissue about 29% and so and another
interesting point about this was that
84% of these patients had received prior
by color to mind so this was the primary
endpoint illustrators kaplan-meier occur
to get a separation at about three
months with a hazard ratio of 0.6 3
which was statistically significant and
this led to a 39 percent reduction in
risk of death anywhere along this curve
which equated to about a four point
eight month survival advantage now when
we look at the radiographic
progression-free survival
this was also statistically significant
with a 60% reduction in the risk of
radiographic progression hazard ratio
point four zero so there was about a
five month delay in progression with
enzalutamide and this was the prevail
trial this is in the pre chemo patient
group 1717 patients were randomized in a
one-to-one fashion to receive
enzalutamide or placebo over had to Co
primary endpoints overall survival and
radiographic progression-free survival
and some of the secondary endpoints were
time to first s sorry initiation of
cytotoxic chemotherapy soft tissue
response PSA response rate greater than
50 and time the PSA progression and it
hit all of these endpoints and some of
the baseline characteristics the median
age of 72 PSA was about 50 in each group
and these patients had
over 80% bone Mets about 60% had soft
tissue ornaments and visceral metastasis
was allowed in this trial whereas in the
abiraterone trial visceral metastases
were not in the pre chemo trials and so
I was about 11 12 % these patients had
and so in the prevailed trial the
overall survival was statistically
significant with a hazard ratio of 0.7
one and there was a 29% reduction in the
risk of death and the now that was in
the first interim analysis but there was
an updated overall survival analysis
because initially it was about a
two-month difference but when they did
the overall survival and the extended
analysis there was about a four point of
form of difference in overall survival
and when we looked at radiographic
progression-free survival again
statistically significant with a hazard
ratio of 0.1 seven and an 83 percent
reduction in the risk of radiographic
progression so in the first analysis at
12 months and 63% of the patients on
enzalutamide were progression free
whereas only 8% of the placebo group was
progression free and when we look at
some other endpoints the time to
chemotherapy there was about an 18-month
difference by so that patients who are
as Ludum I'd did not require
chemotherapy for 18 months and that's
important because it didn't delay the
effects of chemotherapy that can be very
beneficial to the patients and there was
a 28% reduction in first skeletal
related events coughs related events
remember our
fracture surgery to bone radiation to
bone usually because of pain and spinal
cord compression so that's really the
definition of skeletal related events
but if you can prevent fracture in these
patients remember that you know there's
about a 30% mortality and all other
patients who get a hip fracture so some
of the adverse events interest a seizure
and interest seizure risk something you
need to pay attention to even though it
was low it's something that did occur
and in the AFIRM trial seven of 800
patients or 0.9% of nasal Umayyad group
experienced a seizure no patient uh
placebo group experienced a seizure in
the prevail trial the pre chemo trial it
was one in each of the groups that
experienced a seizure and when they went
back and looked at the affirmed trial
and those seven patients two of them
actually had brain Mets another patient
was given an inadvertent dose of IV
lidocaine another patient had cerebral
atrophy
he had history of alcohol abuse and was
originally started on Haldol and then
there was another patient who may have
had a syncopal episode but they thought
that the description was more like a
seizure
so even though those numbers are low is
something you need to pay attention to
and some of the other adverse events of
interest with enzalutamide are fatigue
diarrhea hot flush and hypertension and
so you can see when we talk about grade
1 through 4 there is a difference
between as Luda my placebo but when we
get into the grade 3 and for the more
severe adverse reactions you can see
that there they're much lower but
there's still a little difference and
one thing that sticks out here is the
hypertension great three important for
Baylor on that right lower bottom now
we're not really sure what the mechanism
of action is for hypertension and with
enzalutamide but we do know the Napa
Valley trial about 60% of patients going
into that trial had comorbidity or
hypertension and so the in conclusion
these are the expanded these are the
indications
in 2012 and 2014 is when I received its
in its approval based on these end
points and the trials and the dela singh
is 160 milligrams per day there are 40
milligram caps that you take form at
once there are no food restrictions and
no requirement for steroid core
administration and the adverse events of
interest we mentioned the seizure and
monitoring patients for blood pressure
issues and you know just like all drugs
that we can have reactions in the
cytochrome p450 system and with
enzalutamide if patients are on warfarin
you probably want to conduct additional
high an hour monitoring because the
serum concentration is reduced when you
give an solute amide but these patient's
are being monitored pretty frequently
anyway so when we compare with Alvarado
Rome to enzalutamide they have different
mechanisms of action have errata on as
an antigen bio synthesis inhibitor
enzalutamide is an androgen receptor
antagonist they have they're both
effective before and after chemotherapy
and the endpoints were overall survival
and progression-free survival so they
have improvements in both of those
endpoints and some of the potential
adverse effects we talked about but in
abiraterone
hypertension hypokalemia and LFT
abnormalities and enzalutamide seizures
hypertension and fatigue everyone needs
to be taken on an empty stomach
abiraterone I mean salud amide does not
have any food requirements
abiraterone requires prednisone as Lou
Tamiya does not and when it comes to
cost there is a cost advantage advantage
favoring every room so I don't know how
many of you believe in guidelines are
going to look at guidelines but these
are guidelines from the AE way and their
5 index patients and I'm showing you the
index to
and this is in the pre chemo space but
you can see that a parabola and
prednisone have Class A recommendations
which is their highest recommendation
and so that's the au weight guidelines
and I would really encourage you to look
at that because it takes you step by
step through all the other therapies
that are approved and the NCCN
guidelines also give enzalutamide and
abiraterone category one which is the
highest category recommendation and i
would encourage you to use these
guidelines and it really helps us also
with our payers because when we can show
that these are guideline approved
therapies we rarely get a rejection for
for use of that drug so now we're going
to shift gears a little bit and talk
about AR resistance mechanisms so there
are a number of different resistance
mechanisms that develop in castration
resistant prostate cancer and ARB 7 has
been identified and it seems to be the
most abundant right now in CRP c but
keep in mind that others exist now this
was an important paper by Hansen Arrakis
and his team at Johns Hopkins and this
was published in the New England Journal
in September of 2014 and what they did
was they looked at they had 31 patients
in each arm and these patients were
going to get a balloon or as alert amide
and what they looked at was the ARB
splice variant and when you have this
when you express this variant you have a
resistance to enzalutamide and a veteran
and a rv7 is a splice variant that is
truncated form of the antigen receptor
meaning it's a shortened form of the
antigen receptor that lacks the ligand
binding domain or the C terminal and
this is the target of testosterone
binding to that receptor and so in
essence is the target of enzalutamide
abiraterone but it does not require
testosterone
to be stimulated so it's constituted
when the active as a transcription
factor so it does not require so it
signals without engaging a ligand so
that's kind of a scary thought but
that's something that we've found in you
know the recent years of research and
detection of the ARB 7 is usually in
circulating tumor cells and not only do
these patients not respond to the in
Zulu tomayto rat rat around but they do
poorly their overall survival and
progression is inferior to patients that
don't have the AR b7 splice variant and
so this is this kind of a little cartoon
depicting you know you have the
full-length androgen receptor and you
can see that the C terminal is the
ligand binding domain so testosterone
binds to that and abiraterone and as
luda might require that functional
ligand binding domain in order to be
effective so that would the splice
variant you know during the translation
process this c terminal gets terminated
so it's there's a stop code that
develops and you don't get that C
terminal it develops and so that
abiraterone
and enzalutamide will lose their effect
and this thing will be off on its own
growing and stimulating tumor growth
without even needing testosterone so
these are the three different assays
that are available and there's a hopkins
the end and edna gen which is an immuno
genic assay and this is one that's
actually out there but it's not
commercially available it's being used
in clinical trials and we are actually
working with it right now we just opened
the Tokaido Rowland trial which i'll
talk about and we're using this this
assay to measure a rb7
but Memorial sloan-kettering has an
immuno fluorescent assay in development
and MD Anderson developed one that was
from bone marrow
he's looking at antibodies to a rv7 so
that's not going to be as practical as
doing a blood draw but these are the
upcoming assays that are going to be
available they're not commercially
available yet but hopefully in the next
year or two so when we looked at the
answer in raucous study we found that of
the 18 patients out of those 62 patients
18 patients had the ARD splice variant
and zero had a response so that they
didn't get a PSA of greater than 50%
reduction and the overall survival and
radiographic progression-free survival
were inferior these patients progressed
much more rapidly than patients that did
not demonstrate that variant and so if
you look over here in that left hand box
this is actually when we talk about the
prevalence of a rv7 these are some
combined studies but he before the ARB
seven has been measured before patients
get enzalutamide arrive around our own
and it's about 12% if you look at the
answer in the rocket study it almost
approaches 20% at it so when you look at
this developing after patients get Kim's
aloo tamatar abiraterone 25 percent of
patients in the post enzalutamide
treatment developed the AR d7 splice
variant 51 percent in the post a b and
when you combined a B and enzalutamide
67 percent expressed the variant so in
conclusion you know detection of the rv7
and circulating tumor cells is
associated with resistance to his Aleta
might in Abby and the ARB seven actually
may be used as a biomarker I think that
it may make an excellent biomarker to
predict resistance and so you'll know
whether or not to use it for
enzalutamide we're not using in my
arrival
based on whether or not the patient
already has an AR b7 variant and it may
provide a target to fuel the development
of new therapies that target the error
and terminal domain so some of the new
drugs in development for 2015
going back to the NCCN guidelines this
was 2015 version the NCCN believes that
the best management for any cancer
patient is in a clinical trial
participation in clinical trials is
especially encouraged and really if it
weren't for these clinical trials we
wouldn't have the development the drugs
that we have so this is era and 509 this
is the mechanism of action it's a
antigen receptor antagonist it works
like enzalutamide so that you have those
three mechanisms that blocks they are
signaling the pairs the nuclear
translocation and the DNA binding and
this is a trial this is an f0 trial is
called a Spartan trial it has opened in
October of 2013 and what it is comparing
is it's looking at patients who are high
risk for developing metastases and so
it's looking at men that have high PSA
short doubling times but no metastases
and they are castrate-resistant their
progression on PSA only m0 and so these
are being randomized in a two-to-one
fashion to get Hera and 509 240
milligrams versus placebo and so that is
a trial in progress and we'll see you
know we talked about all these drugs
being approved in the em1 space
hopefully we're going to have these
drugs moved up into indications in the
m0 space which is a real unmet need o DM
201 is another antigen receptor
antagonist in development and the Aramis
trial phase 3 that they're looking to
enroll 1500 patients and 0 castration
resistant prostate cancer it's currently
in row
the primary endpoint is metastasis free
survival secondary endpoints overall
survival time the first sre time to
initiation of chemotherapy and time to
pay in progression and that opened in
January of 2015 and so it's currently
enrolling it now this is a novel agent
collateral toke hole one it's a first in
class three in one molecule that it's an
uphill it purports to have 17 inhibition
androgen receptor antagonist qualities
as well as being an androgen receptor
degraders so they may work on that that
variant so that it just completed a
phase 2 trial and we just opened the
phase 3 this last week we were waiting
actually on the ARB 70 androgen has they
to become available and it was just just
happened so this is the the mechanism of
action of the Lateran it's a small
molecule it has 17 rights inhibition
qualities like abiraterone
a are antagonists like enzalutamide but
what also dippers with this is that they
are be greater so it has all three of
these mechanisms so if it hands up to
show the endpoints and of course when it
and it improves to be what it purports
to be this is going to be a super drug
but as we know in clinical trials
sometimes phase 2 doesn't translate into
phase 3 and so we have to wait for the
results but the nice thing about galleta
roan is that there you don't have to
administer steroids the fasting is not
required they don't believe that it has
any seizure risk because it is not a
gaba one antagonist and it may be active
in this c terminal loss of a rv7 splice
variant so this is the schematic of the
trial we're going to include m1 patients
who have progressed and they're going to
randomize
and the other interesting thing about
this is in order to get into trial in
screening you have to have a detectable
AR v7 in your circulating tumor cells so
that remember the in the studies that I
showed you that it's pretty low rate of
having a rb7 before you use any
treatments so there's going to be a high
screen fail rate for this and they're
going to randomize 170 patients in one
to one to get collateral or enzalutamide
primary endpoint is radiographic
progression-free survival secondary
endpoints are overall survival Scout the
related advance in time to cytotoxic
therapy they're also going to be looking
at biomarkers and quality of life
indicators so what is the rationale for
combination therapy
well by coach Rd neo receptor and
biosynthesis antigen biosynthesis it may
result in a more potent and it is
signaling inhibition than either
approach alone so maybe we can avoid the
escape mechanisms and in become the
combination trials we have the Alliance
phase 3 trial and the J and J PCR 300
won this is the Alliance trial it's a
intergroup trial and it's looking at
Kimmel and ieave my on castration
resistant prostate cancer patients they
are being randomized to get enzalutamide
or enzalutamide plus abiraterone primary
endpoint is overall survival secondary
endpoints are progression-free survival
as well as radiographic progression-free
survival they're going to even look at
using sodium fluoride PET scans to
measure tumor burden so this is in
progress and it opened in May of 2014 so
hopefully we'll get some answers on
combination therapy and this is the jnj
PCR 301 trial which opened in December
of 2014 this is also looking at
combination they're looking to enroll
about 960 patients metastatic castration
resistant prostate cancer patients
we'll be randomized in a one-to-one
fashion to get abiraterone
plus or minus air and 509 which remember
is another energy receptor antagonist in
development right now and the primary
end point is going to be radiographic
with Russian free survival secondary
endpoints are time to pay in progression
time to opiate use in time to
chemotherapy so as far as sequencing
until level one evidence and biomarkers
are available the FDA indications and
the anyway and NCCN guidelines will
really dictate how we sequence these
targeted agents and really it's going to
come down to your own personal
experience with these drugs and how you
feel comfortable and sequencing them but
you know there's still a number of
answers that need to be questions that
need to be answered and hopefully we'll
have those in the next few years but
this is the disease continuum this is
the playing field you can see the red
arrows these are the approved therapies
that have been approved based on overall
survival since 2010 in the pre chemo
space we haven't had rattling salud of
mine sip tea and radium 223 and in the
post chemo setting and salute my
abiraterone cabassa taxol which is a
second line chemotherapy as well as
radium 223 so how do we seek
one-syllable this is my strategy for
sequencing in 2015 so that first thing
that we do is when patients come in that
are being treated on an antigen
deprivation therapy we put them in our
bone health clinic with your DEXA scan
look at vitamin D levels calcium and if
they are osteoporotic we want to prevent
fractures to bone and you can use the
oral or IV bisphosphonates or donoso
that 60 60 milligrams is marketed as
Prolia
really between those choices that really
was the only one to offers level what
eminence fracture prevention and that
was in the halt
trial and then if the patients develop
in that bone metastases then if it's
significant we start them on
either zoledronic acid marketed as meta
or Dennis enameling 20 which is ex Jeeva
and so that's to prevent skeletal
related event so that's how we first
start in treating these patients and
then I believe that the first initial
platform should be immunotherapy now I
don't know if 50 or Provenge is the
ultimate answer it certainly it was the
first immunotherapy to show a survival
imagine an adult solid tumor and that
was in prostate cancer and I do believe
that the the immunotherapy should be
started early in patients that are
minimally symptomatic with the low
disease burden so that you can get more
effective in the in system response and
so whether or not you believe in
immunotherapy is your first choice the
next would be abiraterone or
enzalutamide and so I like to start with
the simple things first going with the
hora Localytics and when it comes to a
bladder in salute amide you know I
showed you the the data they're both
very effective drugs and so the way that
I would distinguish on humans have
rather owner has alluded might is if the
patient has highest significant
hypertension if they have diabetes
whether on insulin or the oral
hypoglycemics or even congestive heart
failure
those were patients said I will probably
start on in Saluda mind and if a patient
has a seizure disorder then I will start
the patient on abiraterone
but I think it's going to be depend on
your comfort level remember even though
abiraterone requires you know the food
requirement it require that they have to
have an empty stomach that they have to
take prednisone and you have to do
monitoring of lfts at first blush it
looks like it's a very difficult drug to
administer but it really isn't you know
find that if you start using it it's
pretty simple and aluna of course is
just like giving our first generation
anti androgens so it's simple to
administer and so I think that you need
to get a comfort level with both of
these if you're going to start
patience and castration resistant
prostate cancer and then after that I'll
move on to radium 223 if the patients
have symptomatic bone Mets again if
these phases develop visceral Mets you
kind of lose that window to use radium
223 and you and radium 223 is being used
I know in combination with things like
abiraterone because it's a six month
administration and so these patients do
progressive PSAs don't really change and
so patients probably need other therapy
in the meantime and then there is a role
for chemotherapy even though we're
putting it off chemotherapy can be very
effective and we're giving it in the
hands of the reasonable oncologist can
be very efficacious and so we start with
docetaxel if patients failed and going
to the second line composite axial and
there is a trial right now for stone on
comparing dosage as composite axial
head-to-head and we're going to have to
see what that shows us to tell whether
or not we should you be using it as a
tax electron so that's my strategy for
sequencing and we're going to go back to
these AR ask questions now is the real
test so that level 1 evidence supports
sequencing abiraterone beforehand soluta
mine true or false so we're going to see
what your answers are here and I want
you to compare this to what you answered
before to see whether or not I've taught
you anything during this lecture okay do
we have the answer
okay
I just we should have some music that we
can play okay
so half of you got it right and half of
you got it correct so it is false it
does we don't have mother what evidence
yet to say that you have to use a
burrata room beforehand salute in mind
okay let's go on to our next question
now that was a sequencing question and
we really don't have evidence to show
that every one is better before ends in
their mind so we'll go on to our next
question
so a trader on and has alluded might
have received expanded indication for
men with castration sensitive prostate
cancer true or false
okay so let's see here we're getting all
our answers in
and so you all said true well I guess I
stumped you on that one
it's actually in castration resistant
prostate cancer prior to docetaxel
remember all these drugs are approved in
the castration resistant setting so that
was just a little I guess it was a trick
question so let's go on to the next
question enzalutamide should only be
taken on an empty stomach true or false
I would sing to you but you'd probably
all leave the conference here
yes
and so the answer that was questioned
for okay the answer is correct a Baretta
zone is administered with abiraterone -
also to prevent hypokalemia decreased
mental corticoid production and prevent
drug induced hypertension halt all three
of those mineral corticoid effects so
looks like the majority of you have
answered that adequately I think we
missed the question on enzalutamide
should be taken only on an empty stomach
can we just go back to that real quick
correct the answer is false it can be
taken with or without food
so not only on an empty stomach
okay well very good I hope that you
learn something from this lecture and I
think that we will probably open it up
to some questions if we have some time
so Larry this is Judd mal I really want
to thank you for a great presentation I
mean an amazing overview of advanced
prostate cancer we we have about a
minute left one quick question that came
in from our we had a great audience one
question that came in regarding Provenge
and the quartile data do you think that
are you kind of a believer that provent
should be sequenced in ferment with a
low PSA i yes I I now that was a post
hoc analysis and I think you were
involved in that Judd but yeah I think
that patients with low PSA you remember
in that quartile data 22 we've got a PSA
of under 22 those patients actually had
about a 13 month median survival
advantage so I do believe that it should
be used early lower PSA and they usually
indicates less tumor volume her tumor
burden and so I think those patients do
better and so the earlier the better I
get that on board first and then start
then and move on to my other therapies
great well great well I think we're
almost out of time again I'd like to
thank dr. Larry Clark very much it was
an excellent presentation I want to
thank the audience for their interesting
questions and participation today and I
want to also mention that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through March of 2016 you will
receive an email from lab groups
alerting you to when this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed
live event so again on behalf of lab
roots and dr. Carr should like to thank
you very much we'll see you next time
enjoy the rest of today's programs